[Music]
hall of fame quarterback bart starr
passed over the weekend at the age of
85. what a career he had in the national
football league five-time nfl champion
two-time super bowl mvp was the mvp of
the nfl in 1966
holds the highest passer rating for the
post season of all time despite all the
other great quarterbacks we've seen in
the past 50 years before the 2019 or
2018 season started peter king had a
chance to talk to aaron rodgers about
his relationship with the lake bart star
what were his letters saying just super
supportive and encouraging and it meant
the world to me because i knew i had the
support of one of the greatest players
of all time and definitely one of the
greatest packers of all time the feeling
from star and wife cherry is mutual
last week i visited starr who lives in
alabama he's recovering from a 2014
stroke
and it wasn't easy but he wanted
desperately to read a message he wrote
to his friend
on the eve of the packers 100th season
you are a strong
leader
terry and i are admiring you
because you are one of the finest men
we have ever met
[Music]
that's something and what a relationship
that bart starr and aaron rodgers had
and chris you know i discovered the nfl
in the early 70s bart starr was already
retired he was going to coach the
packers for eight years from 75 to 83
but you know once you start to learn
about the mythology of the nfl and that
packers team in the 60s bart starr the
quarterback the leader even though the
numbers were nothing then like they are
now i mean the quarterback was a bigger
deal in the 60s they used to actually
call their own plays i remember what a
big deal that was in the 70s when it
shifted away from the quarterback
calling the game on the fly that's what
bart starr did he made the decision play
in and play out what he was going to do
he wasn't being micromanaged not the
quarterbacks were at that time and he
was one of the very best at that time no
one of the very best at that time i mean
mike really i mean right i mean if we're
gonna make a comparison to this day and
age now i mean he's the tom brady of
that era right i mean i think that's the
closest comparison vince lombardi bill
belichick that's kind of synonymous bart
star tom brady yeah guys that were
clutch able to lead teams you know take
the coaching of a tough you know uh kind
of tyrant type of head coach that way
where it's just i'm in charge and this
is the way it is and we do things my way
but the ultimate winner nonetheless and
hey i do feel like sometimes some of
these all-time greats and i know we said
this a little over text you and i
yesterday but they kind of at times i
feel like do get shuffled under the rug
a little bit as far as we don't take
notoriety as them being the greatest
quarterbacks of all time bart starr was
the greatest quarterback of the 60s he
did special things i feel like as time
goes on we do forget these names he's up
there with the johnny unitas of the
world and the sonny jurgensens and the
joe namaths and
you know as time goes on i think we talk
less and less about them
and think about how the rules have
changed and it started in the 70s to
protect quarterbacks to make it easier
to have a passing game used to be you
could mug the receiver all the way down
the field until the ball was in the end
that's right that that one chuck in the
first five yards was a creature of the
mid 70s in an effort to make the game
more offensively productive and thus
exciting and and star thrived as a
passer especially in postseason settings
before those rule changes were made
think about this yeah in the 1966 post
season right star's passer rating was
143.5 wow for the regular season the
average passer rating was 67.4 yeah that
that's it's unbelievable it really is i
mean hey he's still uh and correct me if
i'm wrong stats or anybody but i mean
still the only quarterback to ever win
three straight championships right he
won an nfl championship then won super
bowl one and super bowl two to follow it
up uh to kind of put the nfl you know on
the map as the king over the afl at the
time you ever watched the old things
about the packers and you know vince
lombardi the pressure he was under uh
from the nfl to win those first two
matchups to show that they were the
greater league over the afl but you know
truly uh a great story bart starr
alabama he's really the one that kind of
started the quarterback factory from
alabama right to where you know the ken
stablers and the joe namas and everybody
else that came after it were a product
of what bart starr did there to begin
with
career-high single season passing
yardage for bart starr 2438
as a difference
it was a big deal if you had 200 yards
in a game back in those days
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports